yo bootle C podcast special guest here
you've seen this guy viral as hell they
say they say he sound like little baby
that's what they say yeah uh yo Lil Man
Jay's here uh welcome I know you got a
new song that's coming out soon yes sir
dropping the 29th man what's it called
studio in La studio in La well we are in
LA right now and he came through to do
what he does man let's do it hell yeah
let's get right to it come on
man yeah
man we in the podcast room right now
real 92.3 my boy Bo
yeah I'll be popping now I made a 100K
you see I'm popping now I'm a genius
with my legs while we jotting down I
didn't seen too many fell I took the
proper R with my money bought some mice
now I'm bound to drown B me with my flow
you know that I don't need a opinion I
didn't sign a deal and now riding with a
million seeing that I made it I get paid
for every minut I took City over calling
me the minutes and the people from the
outside like better Fame is good but
scared of call La and lose my life
before I should yeah I like that money
but that Fame be overrated but of course
I love my fans so don't give me
understood one thing raing too hard
might knock me off my hand just too far
I can't give up now because I always had
an in F in the video you know that they
all r four bars I put a number every
lineup in the sentence what's that he
said he switched the voice he did it
twice and I make the moves when I roll
the dice got a 50 piece when I move
right got kind Ho by night move smart
going toose your like quick 60k that's
something competition got nothing sight
what he say I don't know it it I didn't
took you out the store and I just stole
it it I didn't took 100 m on the Flor I
didn't took like 200 out the door they
see me rolling in the B with lot of cash
you think I'm thugging guess I'm young I
shouldn't have it bet call me me love
these toxic girls are good I understand
that but I love it I say call me Savage
not1 you know I'm
right know I'm right all right yeah all
right appreciate you pulling up new song
coming out the 29th hell yeah man go run
it up you can pre-save it all that I
just saw you post the uh the link in
your uh bio and all that exactly any
albums or mixtapes coming man I got a
little uh album dropping the second
second quarter of next year all right
album on the way hell yeah album on the
way man we going crazy there it is came
through one take that thing let's go yes
sir hey appreciate you guys watching
this freestyle we got another one coming
and then another one and then another
one and they're all brought to you by
our good Folks at LRG clothing you
already know what it is LRG been keeping
you fly for years they got so much new
fly gear right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30% off
l-r-g.com another freestyles on the way
presented by LRG